There's any,
there's another strange element to that,
which is that on the one hand,
the,
the radical feminist types that neo Marxists postmodernists are,
are very much opposed to the patriarchy,
let's say.
And that's that unit,
dimensional,
ideological represented,
average listed every prayer,
perhaps the word can be applied to Republican Rome and that's it.
Okay.
Well,
and it maybe it could be applied usefully to certain kinds of tyranny,
but not to a society that's actually functional.
Victorian England and one arguably.
Okay.
But other than that,
and to use the word patriarchy in that and that slapdash way fulfill amateur
tourists.
Absolutely.
You know,
just shows people know nothing about history,
whatever have you had written,
had done no reading.
So,
and so what confuses me about that is that despite the fact that the Patriarchy
is viewed as this essentially evil entity and that that's associated with the
masculine energy that built this oppressive structure,
the antithesis of that,
which would actually be femininity as far as I can tell,
which is tightly associated with care and with child rearing is also denigrated.
So it's like the only proper role for women to adopt is a patriarchal role,
despite the fact that the patriarchy is something that's entirely corrupt.
So the hypothesis seems to be that the patriarchy would be just fine if women
ran it.
So no changes.
It's just that would just be a transformation of leadership and somehow that
would,
that would rectify the fundamental problem,
even though it's hypothetically supposed to be structural.